hey there have been some headlines about
Tesla and about a Tesla car that drove
its owner to the hospital after he
suffered a pulmonary embolism now I will
we agreed that I would make this
disclosure I am a shareholder of Tesla
stock i I do want to get that on the
record so I have clarity this evening
the headlines are not true okay that the
headline just said oh the car drove the
guy to the hospital what happened is
that the driver was driving around in
his Tesla and it was on autopilot and
then he started suffering from a
pulmonary embolism and the Tesla
remained in autopilot while he looked
for the nearest hospital and then he
manually got himself to the hospital so
it basically instead of calling an
ambulance he said we're gonna use the
self-driving the autopilot mode of Tesla
to find a hospital and then after going
about twelve miles down the road he
pulled into the hospital himself
manually steering so the headlines were
wrong Louis but it's still a very
interesting story nonetheless yeah it's
um I mean there are a lot of variables
here like what if he was moving at the
time he was driving farther away from a
hospital right but the idea that you can
use the map feature and and the car in
some type of emergency or whatever
situation and have the car manually
automatically excuse me pilot itself I
mean I guess that's kind of cool right
it just seems like it's it's a nice
feature but of course the the media
outlets and websites are gonna take a
headline like that and run with it now
eventually the cars would be able to
actually take people to the nearest
hospital
we know that currently you can't have a
fully autonomous vehicle you need to
have an able and licensed and aware and
awake and not drunk driver ready to take
control of the vehicle at any time so
these are really autopilot systems not
fully autonomous and the this is
happening but I mean that will be
possible at some point the anti
autonomous vehicle stuff continues
online some people say oh drug smugglers
will be using autonomous cars to smuggle
drugs
people drug smugglers are already using
human driven vehicles for those same
purposes oh well autonomous vehicles
could be followed robbed or hijacked
human driven cars can also be followed
robbed or hijacked for me the real
issues are sort of the legal
infrastructure and we've talked Lewis
about some of the logic of the
programming of these cars how should the
cars be programmed to make certain
decisions about accident avoidance
driving off the road to maybe kill one
pedestrian instead of ten in a crosswalk
etc those are the bigger questions and
questions for which there was no right
answer necessarily and right so that's
some that's complex stuff and legally
even more complex and there's also the
issue of hacking into these types of
cars but I mean that's just a crime like
any other I mean it will be illegal and
crimes happen I don't actually think
that the entire programming logic is
that complex when people say well if the
car could avoid hitting people in the
middle of the street by swerving off the
road and killing one person who's on the
sidewalk I think as a as a fundamental
basis because otherwise it things get
completely out of control the car should
never deliberately break rules of the
road like driving on the sidewalk right
so the car should do whatever it can and
this this is like a common people
crossing in the middle of the road
situation the car should make every
effort to stop as quickly as possible
but driving on to the sidewalk should
not be one of the ways in which the car
should do that and we have to remember
that if people are crossing not in a
crosswalk just in front of a car that
they are actually doing something which
breaks the law and I think once we come
at it from that perspective it'll
simplify a lot of these hypotheticals
well maybe but I mean it all depends on
how many variables you're introducing to
the to the problem and to the
programming I think it's probably more
complicated than then you're suggesting
here but I mean we'll just I'll just
have to wait and see what they come up
with there's gonna be some really rough
patches for sure yeah we will continue
following it no doubt about it